whether you're a beginner or expert po
spinner I can just about guarantee that
when time comes to do a performance
you've done at least one of these
mistakes regardless of what tricks
you're performing or the venue that
you're performing them in trust me
you're going to want to know how to
avoid these five mistakes that hold back
po
performances Drex here from drexfactor
po sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
count down the top five mistakes that I
see people make when they put together
performances so you can avoid them
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys pyroa light toys and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission regardless of how
long you've been spinning or how many
tricks you know learning how to perform
is an entire skill set in and of itself
you can put together the most advanced
string of tricks in the world and it'll
still make very little impact on your
audience if you don't know how and by
the same token some of the simplest poy
tricks can have an enormous impact on
the audience if they're presented
properly so had how do you maximize your
impact regardless of what your skill
level is by avoiding these five mistakes
that nearly everyone does when they
first start performing real quickly
before we dive in if you like videos on
PO spinning and flow Arts be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you know
when I drop a new video and with all
that in mind let's get
started so I doubt it's going to come as
a huge shock to anybody that the vast
majority of Po spinners out there have a
posture more akin to quasim moto than
they do to Michael Jackson many of us
tend to present ourselves with our next
shoulders hunched over our hands drawn
in tightly towards ourselves and a
general slouch that seems to suggest I
feel very uncomfortable being up here
try letting go of some of that tension
and stack up the bones in your back
shoulders and neck one on top of each
other like building blocks now throw
your shoulders back and voila what an
improvement check the before and after I
mean be honest who would you prefer to
watch spinning
but changing our posture is just the
first step we also have to talk about
how we take up space on the
stage po Spinners are so legendary at
avoiding exploring volume that there's
actually a word for it we call it T-Rex
arms and if you've seen anybody spin poy
at all you have seen them tuck their
hands and arms up so close and tight to
themselves that a certain Tyrant lizard
would definitely look on with jealousy
[Music]
really stretch out the amount of volume
that you're taking up not only will this
make you more visible on stage but it'll
also give you more performance options
to play around with don't be afraid to
play around with flowers or the bigger
version of windmills called p truvi and
man heck you can even open up with
classic tricks like the three beat weave
and butterflies to create a new spin on
an old
classic now I do have to stick a pin in
this particular point because the answer
is not always go big and in fact once
you have the option of going big that
also means that you can play around with
the Dynamics between going big and going
small play around with when it feels
appropriate to eat up all that space
versus when it feels right to shrink
down to a smaller size doing so is going
to give your performance Dynamics and
that's going to make it more
entertaining for your audience to watch
so now that we've talked about how to
eat up all this space around you it's
also time to talk about how we get down
no
literally level changes or dancer speak
for how high your body happens to be on
stage in a given point you can reach up
very high or you can squat down very low
depending upon what the effect you're
looking for is in 90% of Po performances
almost all the action happens between
your hip and shoulder level and again
this is where most of us start off but
imagine how much more entertaining it
would be if we were to play around with
the difference between going high and
going low now all of the sudden all
these po moves have a sense of gravity
and Mass to them to say nothing of the
fact that this gives us another tool to
explore Dynamics with and this this is
also another one of those sections where
I have to stick a pin in it because
usually when I tell people to play
around with level changes and
specifically get down low well there's
another mistake that they engage in if
you're like most people when I say get
down low that means to you that you're
going to bend at the waist the problem
is this kind of makes for a really
awkward silhouette on stage and worse it
reduces your Mobility get comfortable
with your plas by standing against the
wall make sure that the back of your
head shoulders buttocks and heels are
all touching the wall practice relaxing
the muscle on the front side of your
shins to let your knees Bend you'll find
as you go down that your upper body has
as much Mobility as it did when you were
standing straight up but in the process
you've taken all that action down to a
lower level this results in a better
silhouette on stage and even better than
that it gives you more options for how
to move which isn't to say that you
should never bend over at the waist but
be very very careful and very very
choosy about when you do if this is
something you employ your audiences will
see it as a moment of pain or intensity
so deploy it wisely and
sparingly and believe it or not our
discussion about how to use space on
stage is not quite at its end because we
still have to talk
about I know this is sacrilege in many
po circles and in some performance
scenarios it is actually completely
impossible and it is still something
that you should Endeavor to do the
cliche of Po Spinners being riveted to
just one spot on stage not moving their
feet is so and sconed in the popular
imagination that it has a name we call
it the tech tree and two to be fair
there are a lot of poy tricks out there
that are really difficult to pull off
without having your body stable and in
one place but that doesn't mean that
that is the only option that you can
choose when you're on stage if you've
got the space to explore then use it see
who's over on stage right who's over on
stage left and everywhere in between the
more you eat up that space the more
interest you add for your audience that
also means that you're probably going to
have to learn a little bit of footwork
in order to get from place to place
without looking super awkward but that
is a topic for another time for right
now I hope you will join me in my
campaign to cut down the tech trees all
right so we have talked about how you
hold yourself on stage and a bunch of
different ways that you can move around
on said stage so what could possibly be
left Yes you heard me make eye contact
with your audience it is going to make
it a more fun experience for them I
swear as much focus and interest as it
takes to do whatever you are with your
poy I guarantee you your audience will
appreciate it if you break that Focus
for just one second at least and look
out to them and let them know that
you're happy they're there and yes I
know it's intimidating to look at at a
room full of people my recommendation
pick a spot in the very back of the room
and focus on that not only will it mean
that you're not focusing on any human
directly but also too it'll mean that
you're broadcasting your performance
across the entire room and it should be
said do not stare at the audience the
entire time that comes off is either
creepy or confrontational pick some
important moments to check in with the
audience maybe right after you land a
really important trick not only does
that give you a minute to catch your
breath on stage but also it gives the
audience a window to express their
appreciation for the performance that
they're
seeing what are some of your favorite
tips for delivering awesome po
performances and what did you think of
my list leave me a comment and let me
know also be sure to like share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
and if you enjoy these videos that I
produce but you're not currently
reporter there's a quick and easy way to
fix that head on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and sign up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome resources and rewards and
even better than that you'll be helping
me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world go check that out please and thank
you and if you are in fact interested in
learning a little bit of footwork to
help carry you around to different parts
of the stage I've done several tutorials
on the PO dance elements of what I do
that I will go ahead and link to as a
playlist down down in the description as
well as up on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourself today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace